大家好,欢迎来到数据要素可信流通技术的木颗课程
今天分享的主题是基于可信硬件的隐私计算框架TrustFlow
我来自蚂蚁密算,也是TrustFlow的开源项目主要负责人
今天分享的内容主要分为以下部分
分别回答Why, What, How这三个问题
并且介绍我们的眼睛路线图
首先来回答第一个问题
为什么需要TrustFlow
在回答这个问题之前
让我们回顾一下什么是可信执行环境
可信执行环境英文缩写T1E
是一种基于硬件的隐私保护技术
它具备安全启动,内存加密
远程认证这三个主要特性
硬件保护了软件的启动过程
防止恶于程序运行
在程序的运行过程中
内存又是被硬件加密的
并且第三方可以随时通过
认证远程认证报告的方式
验证T1E的运行环境
以及其中运行代码的安全
不同于安全独方计算
T1E它是一种中心化计算的模式
我们通常把它称为输扭模式
而MPC我们称为管道模式
更多关于T1E本身的介绍
可以参见一期的目客课程
机密计算与可信执行环境这一阶课
那么为什么需要TrustFlow呢
首先我们需要明白
并不是把应用在T1E运行起来
它就是一个安全的T1E运用了
举个最直观的例子
假如一个T1E中运行的程序
直接将它独到的敏感信息
在日子中输出
甚至上传到公网
那么T1E本身在安全也无忌于事
数据安全的保护是多方面的
任意环节的设计不当
都可能产生数据滥用
只是数据泄漏
在存储安全方面
数据加密以及数据密要的管控
是需要被关心的问题
在传输安全方面
传输通道的数据也是被加密的
并且为了建立从T1E硬件
到传输层的这一个可信链
我们要求传输密要
也受到T1E硬件的保护
在计算安全方面
被硬件保护的程序运行时
还需要向外自证清白
也就是对外提供远程证明服务
第三方可以通过
验证T1E硬认的远程认证报告
来确保执行环境的安全
以及计算代码的安全
Trust Flow就是为了解决上述问题
提出的一套计算框架
接下来
我们来了解一下
Trust Flow为了解决上面的安全问题
做了什么
Trust Flow是一套
基于可信硬件的隐私计算框架
它提供受保护和隔离的执行环境
提供数据安全存储和安全计算的能力
它的整体架构可以参考一下这张大图
Trust Flow底层
对接了多种不同的T1硬件
相应开发了远程认证模块
利用这个远程认证模块
Trust Flow各组件之间
可以互相交连身份
并建立安全的通信连接
在Trust Flow中留转的数据
都是以密谈形式存在的
加密数据所用的数据密钥
与一个授权策略
绑定形成一个数据交囊
并且由KMS统一管理
Trust Flow上层提供了
丰富的可信应用
涵盖AI BI
以及大模型等领域
当这些可信应用想要访问数据时
需要向KMS请求获取数据密钥
KMS会根据可信应用的
远程认证报告进行教验
并且教验它的防温权限
教验的依据就是
前面所说到的授权策略
这就保证了数据仅在授权范围内
被妥善的被提议应用所使用
对于前面提到的数据
将当中的授权策略
Trust Flow设计了一套
灵活的策略协议
它大致包含以下内容
每份数据包含一个数据ID
以及一个数据拥有者的ID
数据的拥有者
或者具备相应权限的机构
可以对该份数据进行多维度的授权
比如它可以指定被授权的机构列表
可以进行算法上的约束
指定算法的类型
参数以及反问的列的范围之类
还可以进行通用约束
比如指定硬件运输平台
是英特尔的还是海光的
比如指定有效的应用执行时间等等
这些策略的配置都可以通过
我们提供的扣断工具中的配置文件来进行实现
那么一个应用介入到Trust Flow框架中
需要做什么改造呢
在介绍之前我们需要再次强调一下
安全的T1应用
并不等于直接把应用在T1内运行起来
为了让T1应用具备前面
所提到的这些安全能力
我们需要对它进行一些改造
在远程认证方面
我们需要对接各种T1硬件
比如英特尔的SGX
TDX
AMD的SEV
海光的CSV
或者是蚂蚁字眼的Hyperinclave等等
数据读写方面
我们需要对接多种存储介质
比如数据库
OSS
加密字盘等
需要做好数据加密
和数据庙的管控
在通信上面
我们也需要保证通信信道的安全
在SGX时代
关键于它本身是LabelS的架构
我们必须对应用进行侵入式的修改
但是一个系统中通常存在多个应用
并且他们大概率是不同语言开发的
这就使得T1应用的改造成本会比较高
并且这项改造工作
对开发人员有一定的学习成本和门槛
但是好在现在T1业界的趋势
是使用SEVM
也就是机密虚拟机
比如TDX,SEV,海光,CSV等
这些都是基于SEVM架构来构造的一个提议的底层硬件
SEVM的一些灵活性给我们提供了一种
别的改造思路
SEVM下面
或者说机密虚拟机
一或是机密容器
它的里面允许运行多个container
基于这个前提
我们提出了CCTF框架
执意过来就是机密计算透明框架
我们的目标是让应用可以无痛的提议化
让天下没有难用的提议
我们将一个可信应用看成一个POD
它包含了一个原始应用的container
和一些可选的set card
这些set card分别是
RA Proxy
它兼容各类提议硬件
并且对外提供RA报告查询服务
RA就是Remote Testation
远程证明的这个意思
Data Capsule Proxy
它提供数据庙存取
数据加减密
数据上传下载等透明接口
它仅服务于POD内部
也就是服务于原始应用的container
TrustFlow Invoid
它是基于开源Invoid开发的流量代理
它负责对应用的出入流量进行统一处理
它也支持流量的明文转发
但它最重要的目的是
为了给密闻流量进行透明加减密
它还提供一种功能
它可以让我们的提供应用之间
进行安全的TRS建联
当然我们后续可以
根据其他的实际需求
继续扩展这套Sidecar的体系
使用这套CCTV的框架
应用的开发者
几乎不需要改变自身的应用代码
就可以将应用安全的提议化了
接下来我们介绍
如何快速上手TrustFlow
观望文档里面
我们已经提供了
详细的操作步骤和命令
这里我们就对整体流程
做一个疏离
第一步是部署Capsule Manager
它就是前面我们架构图里面
提到的可信KMS
它本身也是一个
运行在T1里面的应用
对数据必要
和授权策略
进行统一的安全管理
我们打好了一个Dock镜像
我们可以根据不同的T1硬检
来选择对应的镜像来进行部署
接下来的步骤是数据加密
和数据授权
这个是数据应用者来做的
他们可以使用我们
提供的COI工具来操作
这张图里面
Alice和Bob
分别将自己的数据加密
发送给了可信APP进行计算
并且将数据密要和数据授权策略
上传到了Capsule Manager里面管理
为了保证自己的数据安全
在上传数据密要和数据策略之前
Alice和Bob首先需要
确认Capsule Manager的安全
也就是保证Capsule Manager是可信的
运行在T1里面的
因此Alice和Bob
会对Capsule Manager进行远程认证
并且在远程认证的过程中
同时获取了Capsule Manager的公要
这个公要是被远程认证报告来
进行保护保证的
接下来Alice和Bob
可以使用Capsule Manager的公要
用数字信封的方式
与Capsule Manager进行安全的通信连接
此外Alice和Bob
还会对他们自己的授权策略
进行签名
防止这个策略被钻改
前面这些都是数据准备阶段
在完成这些步骤之后
可信APP就可以启动进行计算了
他会请求Capsule Manager获取
数据密要
用于解密Alice和Bob的数据
而Capsule Manager会对
T1APP进行远程认证
然后教验他的访问权限
只有符合授权策略的可信APP
可以互取到数据密要
从而进行数据的解密和计算
可信APP完成计算后的结果
也会以数据交档的方式进行安全存储
它对应的数据密要和访问策略
也会被Capsule Manager统一管理起来
接下来我们快速浏览一下
相关的命令
有一个更直观的感受吧
在第一步驻Capsule Manager的步骤中
我们只需要运行老可进行
并且进入到镜像中运行服务进程就可以了
这里列了一个仿真模式的镜像
我们可以根据实际的镜像进行镜像的替换
相关的命令也在文档中有详细的介绍
第二步我们使用CRL工具
去进行数据加密和授权
这里我们提供的CRL工具
是一个Python的安装包
但是为了解决我们实际上
遇到的一些依赖的一些问题
避免环境上面出现不同的冲突
我们还是建议在我们的
TrustFlow Release镜像里面去安装CRL工具的安装包
安装完之后
我们可以用里面的CMS Utah命令
去生成数据庙
也可以用Encrypt的命令
去加密我们的数据明文文件
当然这个数据庙
不一定是需要用工具生成的
你也可以自行准备
这个都可以
在完成前面的数据加密之后
我们可以把我们的数据庙
上传到Capture Manager来进行托管
大概可以看一下这边的一个配置文件
就是配置了数据的ID
就是对应的Resource URI
Data Key Base64
就是数据庙Base64之后的结果
这些都是可以写在配置文件里面的
这个配置文件就是一个YAML文件
它包含在前面说的这些数据的URI
数据的Data Key的内容
也包含这个数据的授权策略
比如这个右图这个结的一个粒子
它限制了访问机构
限制了算法参数
限制了计算平台等等
用户还可以另外自己
扩充它的自定义规则
把这个配置文件
用一个剛剛config file的方式
把它配置到我们的命令行的工具里面来
就可以把这个授权策略
一起注册到capital manager里面了
当然这个上传策略的过程中
已经被客户端自己的公司
要进行一个加密和签名的保护
在完成前面的数据准备的步骤之后
我们就可以运行
提EAPP来实际的进行计算了
可信EAPP
我们可以使用cctf的框架来运行
一个最简单的理线应用
只需要集成dataCapsuleProxy
来带为获取数据必要和解密数据就可以了
在EAPP这个container
是这个主进程的容器看来
它只需要关注自己的业务逻辑
并且读取dataCapsuleProxy
解密后的数据就可以了
解密后的数据
会放在POD对应的加密磁盘上面
加密磁盘就提供了一个透明加解密的能力
这个也是对应用层无感的
我们在TrustFlow仓库的一个sample下面
提供了这样子的一个简单例子
进入到example的offlinesample这个目录
我们已经配置好了相关参数
你只需要把公司要放到deploy目录下
并且将Alice和Bob的这个加密数据
放到data目录下面
然后运行dataCompose就可以了
它运行的这个例子
实际是一个求教任务
我们也可以看到一下
它的求教结果的名文
以及命文的一个内容
对于一个在线的一个服务
它我们可以集成CCTF的TrustFlowInvoy
和Raproxy来完成
Raproxy可以对外提供远程证明服务
供用户来进行第三方的教验
TrustFlowInvoy提供了透明加解密的能力
对于来自客户端的加密数据
能够透明解密后转发给APPContainer
APPContainer返回的数据
也会进过它的透明加密
返回给客户端
我们在Example目录下面
也提供了这样子的一个简单例子
进入到这个Example的Online Sample里面
我们已经配置好了相关的东西
同样你需要把Deploy下面的
公司要进行一个配置
然后运行dataComposeUp就可以了
这是一个在线的一个简单的HTTP服务
它只会返回你的请求的内容
这次于一个你跟它对话Hello World
它也会返回一个Hello World的一个
返回的那个结果
可以看一下我们有一个简单的客户端
来访问这个服务
我们客户端发送的Request
是一个JWE加密的数字新风的格式
可以看到都是一个密文的一个格式
我们的实际的APP主Container
它其实没有什么解密的能力
所有的解密的结果都是
通过Invoy解密完之后
转发给这个APPContainer
然后我们看到收到的这个Response
也是一个加密的一个Response
它同样是被TrustFlowInvoy进行一个加密的
通过客户端的一个解密
我们可以看到我们发送的一个
Hello的这个东西已经被服务端收到了
并且整条链路
这个主应用是无感的
除了前面提到的
黑屏体验TrustFlow的方式
我们还有一个SecurePad的产品
在SecurePad all-in-one的安装包里面
已经集成好了这个输流模式
它底层就是使用的TrustFlow
这套整条的数据密要的管控体系
以及它的APP的一个运转的流程
我们可以在白屏的界面上面
进行拖拉拽一些它的预知的这个组件
比如说拿取两个样本表
把样本表读出来之后
把它连线连到隐私求交这个组件里面
这样的话就是可以做到非常快速的
把整个认为跑起来
不需要关心底层的细节逻辑
另外我们的大模型密算平台
本身也是继续TrustFlow的这套框架来完成的
我们有模型训练
评测优化以及在线的推理
这些的能力
后续我们还会继续去
深挖大模型平台的需求
比如说IG agent
等等等等能力
最后来介绍一下我们的眼睛路线图吧
TrustFlow的前身是T1EU
是一个在StickFlow下面的一个密台设备
然后在2023年的4月份
TrustFlow单独出来进行了一个手机开源
它支持了跨越管控
可新的机器学习
然后也有设计了这套
可扩展的授权策略
在2024年的3月份
我们扩充了更多的底层硬件
支持了Intel TDX
还光了CSV
在2024年的4月
大模型密串平台手次推出
然后在2024年的12月
我们推出了CCTF这套框架
支持了T1EU的无通改造
未来我们会去
专注于更好用的TCTF这套框架
并且提供一些Code transparency的
一些能力
关于TrustFlow的分享
大概就是这些内容
如果大家有想更深入了解的话题
可以前往源于官网
这就是我们的开源社区
TrustFlow的下面的仓库
下面提一宿提问
欢迎大家来积极交流